so it was that for a long time when I
waked at night I remembered calm away
again I saw nothing of it but this sort
of luminous panel cut out among
indistinct shout outs like those panels
which the glow of a Bengal light or some
electric projection will cut out and
illuminate in a building with other
parts remain plunged in darkness at the
rather broad base this whole parlor the
dining room the opening in the dark path
by which mr. Swann the unconscious
author of my sufferings would arrive the
front hole when I would head towards the
first step of the staircase so painful
to climb that form by itself the very
narrow trunk of this irregular pyramid
and at the top my bedroom the little
hallway and it's glass pane door for
mamas entrance in a word always seen at
the same hour isolated from everything
that might surround it standing out
alone against the darkness the bare
minimum of scenery such as one sees
prescribed at the beginning is above all
plays for performances in the prevent
provinces needed for the drama of my
impressing is tho tompa consisted only
of two floors connected by a slender
staircase and install it had always been
seven o'clock in the evening there the
fact is I could have answered anyone who
asked me to come by also included other
things in existed at other times of the
day and but since what I recalled would
have been supplied to be only by my
voluntary memory the memory of the
intelligence and since the information
it gives about the past preserves
nothing of the past itself I would never
have had any desire to think about the
rest of Qom play it was all really quite
dead for me dead forever possibly there
is a great deal of chance at all this
and a second sort of chance event that
of our own death often does not allow us
to wait long for the
flavors of the first I find the Celtic
relief very reasonable the souls of
those we have lost our held captive in
some inferior creature in an animal in a
plant and some inanimate object
effectively lost to us until the day
which forbidding if it comes when we
happen to pass close to the tree come
into possession of the object that is
their prison then they quiver they call
out to us and as soon as we recognize
them the spell is broken delivered by us
they have overcome death and they return
to live with us is to say one hour past
it is a waste of effort for us to try to
summon it all the exertions of our
intelligence are useless the past is
hidden outside the realm of our
intelligence and beyond its reach in
some material object in the sensation
that this material object would give us
which we do not suspect it depends on
chance whether we encountered this
object before we die or do not encounter
it for many years already everything
about convoy that was not the theater
and drama of my bedtime had ceased to
exist for me when one day as I returned
home my mother seemed that I was cold
suggested the contrary to my habit I
have a little tea I refused at first and
then I do not know why I changed my mind
she sent for one of those squat plump
case called petite my lemon that looked
as though they have been molded in the
grooved valve of a scallop shell and
soon mechanically oppressed by the
gloomy day the prospect of another sad
day to follow I carried to my lips a
spoonful of the tea in which I had let
soften a bit of a dilemma but at the
very instant one the mouth full of tea
mixed with cake crumbs touched my palate
I quivered attentive to the
extraordinary thing that was happening
inside me a delicious pleasure had
invaded me isolated without my having
any notion as to his cause it
immediately rendered the vicissitudes of
life unimportant its disasters
inoculates its brevity illusory acting
in the same way that love acts by
filling me with a precious essence or
rather this essence was not really
inside me
I'd ceased to field mediocre contingent
mortal where could it have come to me
from this powerful joy I sensitives
connected to the taste of it see in the
cake but that it went infinitely far
beyond air could not be of the same
nature where'd it come from what did it
mean how could i grasp it I drink a
second mouthful which I find nothing
more than in the first a third that
gives me a little less than a second is
time for me to stop the virtue of the
drink seems to be diminishing clearly
the truth I am sinking seeking is not in
the drink but in me the drink is a walk
in it in me but it does not know this is
truth and can do no more than repeat
indefinitely with less and less force
this same testimony which I do not know
how to interpret which I want at least
to be able to ask it again and find
again intact available to me soon for a
decisive clarification I put down the
cup and turn to my mind it is up to my
mind to find the truth but how such
grave uncertainty whatever the mine
feels overtaken by itself and it went
when when if the seeker is also the
obscure country where it was seat and
we're all its baggage will be nothing to
it seek not only that create it is face
to face with something that does not yet
exist and that only it can accomplish
then bring to its lights and I begin
asking myself again what it could be
this unknown state which brought with it
no logical proof but only the evidence
of its Felicity its reality and whose
presence the other states of
consciousness faded away I want to make
it reappear I returned in my thoughts to
the moment when I took the first
spoonful of tea I find the same state
again without any new clarity I asked my
mind to make another
effort to bring back once more the
sensation that is slipping a wife and so
that nothing may interrupt the thrust
with which I will try to grasp it again
I cleared away every obstacle every
foreign idea I protect my ears and my
attention for the noises in the next
room but feeling my mind grow tired
without succeeding I doubt compel it to
accept the very distraction I was
denying it the thing of something else
to recover its strength before supreme
effort then for a second time I created
an empty space before I confronted again
with the still recent taste of that
first mouthful I feel something
quivering and shift try to rise
something that seems to have been
unanchored at a great depth I do not
know what it is but it comes up slowly I
feel the resistances resistance and I
hear the murmur of the distances covered
Celt sweetie belle t decia of fond de
moi suit what at a demolish the souvenir
of the UL li assets avail Thom Tillis
feverish gum wall mr. de butthole one
took office in 10 pence each about
swallow her frame nerd who should i come
home last as he Sadler to be on the cool
air over me mission / d steyn get a film
with about a commercial interpreter see
blur the man had wielded a 1-yard josiah
cantando hand is on a safety harbor
campagna las available de tomate
followed the kelsey four stars practical
year became a bach capacity derivatives
you scholar so fast by clear conscience
sue souvenir last not consulate action
and talents turn it on TK vision to seal
viscosity even while soooo vector for
the wall should say met no fishing
solely on you said aletta hetero de sol
de patata he c0 montagem it's a 3d for
no como se
a shock for elastic in B Jordan test
facility to drove important back on CL
assists la du Bois Monta on pants on
some tamales on me odo ja v avid easy
orden de mal kids LS o magician Penn
redonkulous souvenir madaba sagoo city
soon be repeatable photo Batman greedy
momentum a condo a cosco sucio larger so
ta pegando obama's khojaly we do Bonjour
on sashabaw matant Leone Maffei a palava
comparison and fusion de tela de la
ville apenas la navaja play a Vulcan
genius Christie protect Oscar on al
souvenir on Al Sabah 33 so emotionally
tablet the petitioner imagine aqui TCG
of the convoy costly adulthood razon
patel pasco decision video nevada
risotto olla memoir Riano COV fair
tricity designation laughs Alma a
solution okey cokey our deputies a cigar
oh so civil Susan pleases severe vivo
sated a body you also may ye Ave
polyolefin expulsion killer Bobby to
handle a conscience hey condom paciencia
Vienna subsist operable desert la peli
discusiones shows soul proof he'll be
pretty vas pretty material Cassie salt
proceed on load el asado host on Colonel
Tom comme des armas a play at unless be
hey should I read the tudors a 40 softly
she'll solar good at presque and Papa
baby fish evil sunil IDK Jacques Ellul
good Mossad Madeline chomping on until
midoonam account cottage industries
cousin co a useful met habia entrado de
grupo process leading me on this year
who OC tula game is on visual who set
him up they said it's a humble vacuum
and pickled at the artists applique opt
Papillon darkness Allah shall darken a
beacon street for me paranoid area
support on kk surge have a huge cloud
Erik Lamela vila de pila Mohammed Andrew
Scott's while a pallet of Laplace who or
more way upon occasion a linear jennifer
ehle cruz is shannon company are 0 20
people a calm down Suzu foolishly
japanese abuser tompa Donald body
porcelain doll on Pluto the video of
soda pataskala Andy stanky a penny
something clumsy CTO second Roman circle
LCD fiancée to the end a flared in
masonic personage consistently Haqqanis
hablo de mamon better nom de florida
doorashada a cellco partnership suan le
navas de la vie Varna le pavillon de
Valera adoptee Lucille agrees to
comprises of a home to flight
performance validity a softie village of
them to mott st